"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
>> DONALD TRUMP IS THE WRONG
PRESIDENT FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> WE SAW A FAILURE OF THE
GOVERNMENT THAT TRIED TO DENY
THE VIRUS, THEN TRIED TO IGNORE
IT, THEN TRY TO POLITICIZE IT.
>> NERO FIDDLED WHILE ROME BURNS
BURNS.
TRUMP GOLFS.
UNDER THIS ADMINISTRATION,
AUTHORITARIANISM HAS TAKEN ROOT
IN OUR COUNTRY.
>> WHAT WE GET INSTEAD IS CHAOS,
THE VISION, AND A TOTAL OF THEIR
OF EMPATHY.
>> Greg: I DON’T KNOW ABOUT
YOU, BUT I DON’T THINK THEY LIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
HE’S RESPONSIBLE FOR COVID, HE
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ECONOMY.
HE IS NOT JUST HITLER ANYMORE,
NOW HE IS NERO.
HE’S AN EVIL AUTOCRAT WHO EATS
KITTENS, PROBABLY WITH CATCH UP.
IN SHORT, IT WAS JUST A DRAMATIC
READING OF WHAT YOU’VE SEEN ON
CNN FOR YEARS.
BUT ABSOLUTELY NO POLICY.
YET, MINUS MEASURABLE FACTS,
THEY ARGUED UNMEASURABLE
OPINIONS STOLEN FROM MORNING
JOE’S DREAM DIARY.
HEY, COVID, NOT ONLY DID TRUMP
SHUTDOWN TRAVEL EARLY ON AGAINST
THE DEMOCRAT WISHES, HE ALSO
GAVE EACH STATE THE ABILITY TO
CHOOSE A PATH.
SO MUCH FOR INACTION AND
AUTHORITARIANISM.
HE ALSO DIDN’T SPREAD DEATH INTO
REST HOMES.
I THINK THAT WAS A DEMOCRAT.
>> COVID IS A SYMPTOM, NOT THE
ILLNESS.
OUR NATION IS IN CRISIS IN MANY
WAYS, AND COVID IS JUST A
METAPHOR.
>> Greg: MAY BE SET THIS ONE
OUT, FELLA.
WHAT ABOUT EMPATHY?
THIS IS COMING FROM A PARTY WHO
DEEMED YOU DEPLORABLE, THAN A
REDEEMABLE, OFFERING A CANDIDATE
WHO SAID MANY OF YOU WERE JUST
BAD PEOPLE.
DON’T LECTURE US ON EMPATHY,
DEAR DEMOCRATS, AS YOU DEEM US
RACIST FOR VALUING THE POLICE, A
DON’T FORGET HOW MANY KIDS YOUR
HUSBAND PUT IN CAGES, MICHELLE
BEARD AND ALL THE DRONING.
BUT AT LEAST SHE IMPLORED US TO
BE BETTER PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, AFTER ONE SPEAKER
BEFORE HER ACCUSED TRUMP OF
MURDER, BUT YOU REALLY NAILED
TRUMP, SAID THE PRESS, AS IF WE
DIDN’T SEE THAT COMING.
BUT NOTICE WHAT WE DIDN’T SEE IT
ALL, BESIDES TRUTH.
HOW ABOUT THE VIOLENCE?
INNOCENT PEOPLE ATTACKED ON THE
STREET OR DRAGGED OUT OF CARS?
DOUBLE DIGIT JUMPS AND SHOOTINGS
AND MURDERS.
IS IT BECAUSE THE DEMS LIKE
EMPATHY CUSTOMER CHURN.
YOU LET US
TO A PLACE WHERE MOBS CAN
BRUTALIZE CITIZENS AT WELL.
AT THE PARTY PREACHES EMPATHY
WHILE THEIR VERY OWN STREET TEAM
EXACTS MOB JUSTICE WITH LASERS
AND FISTS.
ALAS, THEY SAID NOTHING ABOUT
THIS, MAY BE BECAUSE, AS BARACK
USED TO SAY, THEY BUILT IT.
JESSE, I WAS WAITING FOR YOUR
COMMENTARY ON THIS BECAUSE I
DIDN’T SEE YOU ON
"SPECIAL REPORT."
THIS WAS IN ONE-WAY KIND OF LIKE
A TELETHON FOR TRUMP DERANGEMENT
SYNDROME.
LOOK WHAT CBS HAS DONE TO THEIR
MENTAL SPACE.
>> Jesse: I DON’T KNOW, WHEN
THE BRUCE SPRINGSTEEN MUSIC
STARTED PLAYING I WAS STARTING
TO FEEL IT, I WAS ABOUT READY TO
VOTE FOR EVA LONGORIA AND
MICHELLE OBAMA.
THEN I REALIZED THEY’RE NOT
RUNNING.
THIS IS MY "SPECIAL REPORT"
ANALYSIS.
THE BEST PART OF THE WHOLE NIGHT
WAS THE LITTLE VIDEO SAYING THEY
DID WITH JOE BIDEN BEING THE
AMTRAK GUY.
I THINK THAT HIGHLIGHTED HIS
TOUCH WITH BLUE-COLLAR PEOPLE.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY PORTRAYED
AFRICAN-AMERICANS REALLY
PROMINENTLY AND THEY REALLY
HAMMERED THE COVID-19 STUFF, AND
THEY REALLY WERE FOCUSED IN ON
WINNING BACK THE RUST BELT AND
THOSE OBAMA-TRUMP VOTERS.
YOU WANT ME TO TELL YOU THE
TRUTH?
HERE’S THE TRUTH.
VIRTUAL CONVENTIONS ARE
PATHETIC.
IT’S NOT THE DEMOCRAT’S FAULT,
IT’S THE CHINESE COMMUNISTS’
FAULT, EVEN THOUGH THE DEMOCRATS
WON’T TELL YOU THAT.
IT WAS A SERIES OF BADLY
DELIVERED AND KIND OF AWKWARD
STATE OF THE UNION RESPONSES
POORLY EDITED TOGETHER.
FAILED MAYORS, FAILED GOVERNORS,
FAILED CANDIDATES.
NOTICE THE TWO BRIGHT SPOTS
WEREN’T POLITICIANS.
AND THEY JUST PAPERED OVER ALL
THE VIOLENCE AS THE BODIES PILE
UP, AND THIS RIDE FOR THE LAST
COUPLE MONTHS HAS CAUSED OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS IN DAMAGE.
THEY TOLD LIES ABOUT GAUGES AND
BOXES AND PPE.
I’M OKAY WITH THAT BUT HERE’S
THE THING, JOE BIDEN WAS AN
AFTERTHOUGHT.
JOE BIDEN, THE ONLY TIME HE
REALLY CAME OUT, THEY SAT HIM
DOWN IN A CHAIR AND HAD HIM ASK
OTHER PEOPLE WHAT TO DO.
THAT JUST WALKS RIGHT INTO THE
TRAP THAT TRUMP HAS LAID FOR HIM
THAT HE HAS NO VISION AND HE IS
A PUPPET, WHICH DOESN’T HAVE A
LOT GOING ON UPSTAIRS.
AND HE DID THAT TO HIMSELF, AND
FINALLY, IT JUST DIDN’T HAVE THE
FEEL OF THE WINNING PARTY.
>> Greg: I THINK YOUR POINT IS
WELL TAKEN.
THE REPUBLICANS AND TRUMP BETTER
LEARN FROM THIS.
A GIANT ZOOM MEETING IS A
CATASTROPHE.
KATIE, THEY AVOIDED EVERY
POSITION, WHETHER IT BE ON
ENERGY OR FRACKING ORGAN CONTROL
OR CRIME PURITY THINK IT’S
POSSIBLE THE DEMOCRATS REALIZE
THEIR POSITIONS ARE SO NUTS THAT
THEY CAN’T TELL PEOPLE
ABOUT THEM?
>> Katie: I HEARD A RECIPE
THAT TRUMP GOT THE RECIPE FOR
CATCH UP WITH KIM JONG UN, HE
GOT THE RECIPE IN A BIG ENVELOPE
SO THAT IS WHERE THAT CAME FROM.
HOW DO YOU DEFEND YOUR POSITION
ON THE POLICE WHEN THE PARTY IS
FIGHTING ABOUT POLICE.
JOE BIDEN IS TRYING TO SAY HE’S
NOT FOR DEFUNDING POLICE, BUT
THE SECOND HE SAYS THAT, LIKE
TODAY, THERE IS AN ERUPTION
INSIDE THE LEFT WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ABOUT HOW
THAT’S TO MODERATE AND HE’S PART
OF THE OPPRESSION THAT THEY WANT
TO TAKE OUT AND HE’S PART OF THE
SYSTEMATIC PROBLEM THAT THEY
CLAIM TO BE WANTING TO FIGHT,
BUT MICHELLE OBAMA SPEECH WAS
GREAT UNTIL YOU STARTED
FACT-CHECKING IT.
AND WHEN HE STARTED LOOKING AT
THE FACTS OF WHAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF GOING
BACK TO AN OBAMA-ERA STYLE
GOVERNANCE, THE ECONOMY AT A
NUMBER OF OTHER ISSUES, PEOPLE
SAY, YOU KNOW, THIS IS KIND OF A
DOWNER.
I’M NOT REALLY SURE WHAT
HAPPENED TO HELP, WITH ALL OF
THE NEGATIVITY.
SECOND, DO WE REALLY WANT TO
START GOING BACKWARDS INSTEAD OF
FORWARDS WITH NEW CANDIDATES,
NEW IDEAS, AND RELIVE EIGHT
YEARS OF WHAT WE SAW WITH THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION?
>> Greg: DANA, THE GREAT KYLE
SMITH OF "NATIONAL REVIEW" SAID
THAT AFTER LAST NIGHT, IT LOOKED
LIKE A REFERENDUM ON TRUMP’S
PERSONALITY.
DO YOU THINK THAT’S ENOUGH?
DO YOU THINK IT’S ACCURATE, AND
YOU THINK THAT’S ENOUGH?
>> Dana: IT’S INTERESTING
BECAUSE I THINK THE FIRST NIGHT,
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS WANTED TO DO
WAS TO PROSECUTE THE CASE
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP, FROM
THEIR PERSPECTIVE.
THEY’RE GOING TO SAY SOME
THINGS, LIKE JESSE SAID, HE’S
OKAY WITH SOME OF THE THINGS
THEY SAID BECAUSE IT’S POLITICS
AND THAT’S WHAT THEY’RE GOING TO
DO, SO PROSECUTING THE CASE
AGAINST HIM INCLUDES HIS
PERSONALITY AND HIS TONE, AND
LACK OF EMPATHY, FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE.
THAT’S WHAT THEY WERE TRYING TO
DO THEN.
TONIGHT IS WHERE THEY TRY TO
PIVOT AND NOW THEY’RE GOING TO
TRY TO MAKE THE CASE FOR
JOE BIDEN, SO THEN WE CAN GET
THAT COMMENTARY NEXT.
I DO THINK IT’S GOOD FOR THE
REPUBLICANS, THE DNC HAD TO GO
FIRST IN THIS NEW, VIRTUAL WORLD
BECAUSE THEY COULD SAY WOW, WE
WERE PLANNING SOMETHING LIKE
THIS BUT I WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE
EVERYBODY, IF YOU’RE GOING TO BE
ON ZOOM, YOU HAVE TO TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF EFFORT TO MAKE
THAT SHOT LOOK GOOD, AND I’M NOT
JUST SAYING THAT YOU’RE GOING TO
BE ON THE DNC CONVENTION.
I’M SAYING IF YOU’RE GOING TO DO
A CONFERENCE CALL WITH YOUR
BOSS, THERE ARE THINGS THAT YOU
CAN DO.
YOU CAN GOOGLE IT, THERE ARE
SOME GOOD TIPS ON THERE, AND YOU
CAN GET A LITTLE BIT OF A LIGHT,
MAKE IT LOOK A LITTLE BIT
BETTER, DON’T STAND SO CLOSE TO
THE CAMERA, DON’T BE LOOKING
DOWN AT THE CAMERA.
I’M SURPRISED THEY DIDN’T HAVE
BETTER PRODUCTION VALUE FROM
THAT PERSPECTIVE BUT FROM THE
DEMOCRATS’ PERSPECTIVE,
REMEMBER, THIS CONVENTION IS FOR
DEMOCRATS AND IF WE CAN ALL LOOK
AT IT AND CONSIDER ALLIES AND
THINGS, BUT I THINK THE GLOOM
AND DOOM IS MATCHING THE MOOD OF
THE DEMOCRATS, AND WHEN YOU SEE
ENTHUSIASM AGAINST DONALD TRUMP,
I THINK THEY WERE TRYING TO
AMPLIFY THAT.
>> Greg: IT’S A FAIR POINT
THAT THEY’RE NOT REALLY RUNNING
BIDEN, THEY’RE BASICALLY RUNNING
TO BEAT TRUMP.
THEY JUST WANT TRUMP OUT SO IT
MAKES SENSE THAT THEY FOCUS ALL
IN ON TRUMP, BUT SHOULDN’T THEY
HAVE ACTUALLY SAID WHY WE SHOULD
VOTE FOR YOU TOO?
>> Juan: I THINK THEY DID.
BERNIE SANDERS GAVE A PRETTY
GOOD SPEECH WHERE HE SAID HE
VIEWED TRUMP AS AN
AUTHORITARIAN, SOMEONE WHO WANTS
TO DELAY ELECTIONS, SOMEONE WHO
SAYS THE PRESS IS THE ENEMY OF
THE PEOPLE, SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO
MAKE BASELESS CLAIMS ABOUT VOTER
FRAUD AND TAKE APART THE
POST OFFICE.
ON A BASIC LEVEL YOU COULD SAY,
BOY, I DON’T WANT TO VOTE FOR
THAT.
BUT I THINK AT THE END OF THE
WEEK, AT THE END OF THIS
CONVENTION, WHAT’S GOING TO BE
REMEMBERED FROM LAST NIGHT,
MICHELLE OBAMA’S SPEECH.
AND WHY IS IT GOING TO BE
REMEMBERED?
I HAVE TWO REASONS.
ONE IS THE FACT THAT SHE SAID
VERY CLEARLY, THE INCUMBENT,
DONALD TRUMP, LACKS EMPATHY.
IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THE WAY HE
TREATED PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIED,
JOHN McCAIN.
I CAN THINK OF JOHN LEWIS, I CAN
THINK OF JOHN DINGELL.
THE WAY HE TREATED THOSE PEOPLE
IN DEATH, THAT IS PRETTY STRONG
EVIDENCE HE LACKS EMPATHY.
AND SECONDLY, MICHELLE OBAMA
SAID, YOU KNOW, DON’T THINK THAT
THINGS CAN’T GET WORSE.
DON’T THINK THAT THOSE
AUTHORITARIAN INSTINCTS CAN’T SO
EVEN MORE CHAOS AND DIVISION AND
THE SENSE OF, THINGS IN OUR
COUNTRY ARE JUST HEADED IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION.
THAT THINGS CAN GET WORSE AND WE
NEED TO BE AWARE OF THAT AND
DEAL WITH IT AND SPEAK TO IT AND
VOTE IN NOVEMBER.
>> Greg: THAT IS WHAT THE
MEDIA’S DOING, IT’S ALWAYS GOING
TO GET WORSE.
BECAUSE THINGS ARE FINE, THEY
ALWAYS HAVE TO SAY "IT’S GOING
TO GET WORSE!"
AND HAS PROBABLY BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE.
I DON’T KNOW, I WOULD RATHER
HAVE A LEADER WHO LACKS EMPATHY
AND DOESN’T BUILD -- HAVE BODY
BAGS COME IN EVERY WEEK.
I WOULD RATHER HAVE A TWEET-ER
WHO IS A DOVE RATHER THAN LETS
PEOPLE DIE.
>> Juan: THE VIRUS HAS A LOT
OF BODY COUNTS.
>> Greg: WELL THAT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH TRUMP.
HE DIDN’T CREATE THE VIRUS IN
THE LAB.
>> Juan: THE VIRUS HAS
RESULTED IN A LOT OF DEATHS.
>> Greg: WHAT WARS HAS TRUMP
STARTED?
>> Juan: HIS LACK OF ABILITY